repente
sombra de mi bien esquivo imagen del
hechizo que más quiero bella ilusión por
quien alegre muero amable ficción por
quien penosa vivo si al imán de tus
gracias atractivo sirve mi pecho de
obediente acero pero que me enamora
lisonjero si has de burlarme luego
fugitivo más razonar
no puedes satisfecho que triunfa en mí
tú tiranía y aunque dejas burlado el
lazo estrecho que tu forma fantástica
seguía poco importa burlar brazos y
pecho
si te labra prisión mi fantasía
sor juana inés de la cruz
vieja loca
eso fue lo que pensó mi pequeñito
cerebro de 12 años la primera vez que
escucho este poema
quien diría que ahora tiene un lugar muy
especial en mi corazón ya que gracias a
éste descubre y pasión y mi vocación
para los que no ubican quién es sor
juana inés de la cruz les traigo un
apoyo visual
también sale en el de 100 ahorita pero
no vamos tan modernos entonces de 200
bueno ya que todos tenemos ubicados a la
vieja loca está
vengo a contarles realmente lo que me
gusta de este poema tiene una filosofía
muy muy
[Música]
habla del amor y la devoción que le
tenía sor juana al arte
que dio su vida por él
se ligan las cabras
y pues ya vamos a empezar a contarles
que yo siempre fue una niña a todo lugar
siempre que pedían que alguien
participara en algo yo levantaba la mano
porque creen que estoy entiendo
entonces a mí me toca recitar este poema
en mi secundaria
y pues obviamente yo pensaba que sor
juana estaba loca porque no entendía las
palabras de una poetisa tan grande a mi
madurez de 12 años
pero empecé a crecer
y me encontré con los iconos
me encontré con bowie me encontré con
garcía márquez en lo personal me encanta
van gogh
y cada vez me hacían más sentido las
palabras de sor juana porque me enamoré
del arte me encontré con algo que me
apasionaba me encantaba y sentía yo que
volaba cada vez que lo hacía y a mis 12
años dije quiero ser artista un tiempo
fue actriz un tiempo fue cantante hasta
que me establecí en directora de cine
llegó un emocionadísimo
con el hambre de comerme el mundo a
contarles todos mis planes a un maestro
llegó súper emocionada le cuento que voy
a hacer artista y que me encanta el arte
es a la charla él
de seguro y también pienso vieja loca y
me dijo algo pues muy fuerte para mí me
dijo cuando tú crezcas pues vas a
cambiar de opinión el arte es un hobby
es una fiebre pasajera no vas a crecer y
vas a hacer otra cosa
y yo me quedé así como qué
me estás diciendo y siento que cuando
uno es artista no sé si haya artistas en
el público pero siento que cuando uno es
artista siempre te encuentras con este
tipo de gente en el camino que les dices
voy a estudiar cine y te voltean a ver
así como hoy
pobrecita
juanito dale 5 pesos pobrecitos artistas
el típico te vas a morir de hambre si
les dijera cuántas veces me han dicho
eso
y pues de cierta manera de la crees de
cierta manera dices lo mejor y si mínimo
yo me quedé con esa idea dije pues
crecer y cuando esté grande haré otra
cosa no sé qué porque lo que me apasiona
me dijeron que no entonces a ver qué
hago y el arte pues va a ser mi hobby
llego a la prepa
y me dicen que si haces este curso tú te
gradúas siendo maestra de inglés
obviamente niña todo lo que siempre
levanta la mano dijo yo quiero y déjenme
decirles que para mí ser maestra ha sido
una de las cosas más difíciles que he
hecho en mi vida tenía yo a 35 niños de
quinto de primaria que no me ponían
atención y por ende no aprendían nada y
pues yo llegó un momento donde dije me
rindo ya no puedo
pero llegué a mi casa
y empecé a hablar conmigo mismo dije a
mí misma para que eres tú buena
le puedas enseñar a estos niños
para el arte
y quieren saber cómo logré que 35 niños
de quinto de primaria pasarán su examen
de inglés
[Música]
no no fue tik tok fue vogue de madonna
así como lo ven con
epifanía
en este momento yo me di cuenta que el
arte es muchísimo más poderoso de lo que
todos nosotros lo creemos me di cuenta
que el arte es una de las pocas cosas
que siempre va a trascender porque el
mundo necesita el arte y el arte siempre
va a necesitar el mundo
el arte no es un hobby el arte no es una
fiebre pasajera el arte es un trabajo y
es uno de los trabajos más hermosos que
existen yo estoy plenamente agradecida
el arte por haberme elegido como su hija
y gracias a todo esto
me di cuenta
sor juana sor juana no estaba tan loca
pero yo yo sí
[Aplausos]